-I know a lot of people ou
there that find math boring.
-Oh.
-Yeah, math. Well, we --
we've updated math
to make the equations
more about stuff
that you can relate to.
It's time for
"Popular Mathematics."
Here we go.
♪♪♪♪
-♪♪ Popular Mathematics ♪♪
♪♪ Mathematics ♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-That's my favorite --
-I love that song.
-That's my favorite song. Yeah
♪♪♪♪
-♪♪ Popular Mathematics ♪♪
♪♪ Mathematics ♪♪
-Do the robot.
-Unbelievable.
You guys are great.
Let's take a look
at our first equation here
You see what I'm saying?
-Oh.
-So that's how it works.
So if you take...
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Yeah. How about this one?
If you take...
-Ohh.
[ Applause ]
Two hours later.
-Here's another one.
Doesn't really --
They don't travel well.
-Yeah, they don't travel well.
♪♪ Soggy taco ♪♪
[ Clap, clap, clap-clap-clap ]
-It's just instinct.
I've never done that befor
in my life.
[ Laughter ]
If you take...
If you take a guy in Brooklyn...
-Oh!
-[ Laughter ]
-"Yo." "Yo."
-Here's another one.
-Oh.
-And, finally, if you take..
That's all the time we hav
for "Popular Mathematics."